[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur verließ
welt heute gibt es ein richtig leckeres
rahmen kuchen rezept das ist original
vor meiner freundin iris und die ärzte
bei ihr gab es früher einen bäcker oder
konditor und er hat es früher gemacht
und dann ist die bäckerei leider
geschlossen worden es gab kein kind was
es weiter geführt hat und sie hat lange
experimentiert und hat dann fließt es
trotzdem
und ich bin jetzt mal gespannt der teig
das ist ein öl teig das heißt hier
beträgt der muss ja immer ein bisschen
auch gehen quark öl teig den kann man
immer sofort zu bereiten und so mache
ich das jetzt auch für den quark öl teig
verwende ich 300 gramm mehl 100 gramm
zucker 250 gramm magerquark 90 kam und
öl dann nehme ich jetzt sonnenblumenöl
ein päckchen backpulver und prise salz
ich würde jetzt einfach zuerst einmal
die trockenen tut hatten also mehl
zucker backpulver und salz einfach
schlimm zusammenrollen und das ist halt
echt ne cola kuchen den man schnell
zubereitet und man hat einfach von
blechkuchen und wirklich was für viele
menschen hier kommt jetzt der magerquark
dazu dass und dann noch das frühe und
dann könnt ihr den teig entweder mit den
händen verkneten oder kurz mit den
knethaken
[Musik]
ich nehme jetzt hier einfach mein
backblech das perforierte mit den
löchern mit back folie und dem bug
rahmen beim kramen ist übrigens so ich
nehme man die lange seite steckt sie
ineinander hier auch die lange seite
muss man sich einfach einmal merken und
dann so der morath macht sind immer
falsch und auch die kurze an die lange
seite
das geht am einfachsten und dann als
auseinander ziehen und das ersetzt
einfach das typische backblech packt ein
bisschen gleichmäßiger und vor allem
auch schneller
den teig nehme ich jetzt schätzen fester
teig deswegen kann man ihn ja auch ganz
gut kneten und jetzt schön in die form
rein drücken und dann den rand
hochziehen
wenn es ein bisschen klebt entweder die
hände ein bisschen fetten oder mail
darauf streuen
[Musik]
so sieht der teig doch perfekt aus und
jetzt kommt da eine rahmen füllung rhein
und die raumkühlung dies wirklich super
lecker
dafür verwende ich 800 800 gramm saure
sahne 400 gramm sahne 105 zucker etwas
vanille extrakt 30 kampfstärke
zitronensaft ein bisschen abrieb und zum
bestreuen nehme ich dann auch zimt
zucker
sodann habe jetzt die iris gefragt habe
sag gerissen die rahmen füllung kommt da
kein ei und die antwort war bloß kai
also kein 1
weil wenn der gebacken hier stand ist er
noch babbel ich also warm unterkühlte ab
und wird fest und dann das sagt sich so
ein ram kuchen hast du noch nie gegessen
also machen wir denn so schlimm ist
einfach die gleiche schüssel die braucht
ihr nicht auswaschen
da kommen die zutaten rhein mit hier die
saure sahne mit rein und der
zuckergehalt ist auch relativ gering
weil ja noch zimt zucker drauf kommt und
ich mag es auch sowieso nicht worden
kuren zu süß ist deswegen mach es doch
jetzt die normale gerne ja es ist viel
aber es hat auch ein ganzes viel zucker
bisschen vanille extrakt
mit dem zitronensaft etwa messlatte eine
ganz kleine prise nur zitronenschale und
da immer schön darauf achten dass die
schale auch zum verzehr geeignet ist und
dann noch die stärke dies zum binden da
jetzt einfach alle zutaten schön cremig
verrühren
[Musik]
und der arme ich packe ich gerade kuchen
im pflaster
hast du dir weg gemacht
ja für dich wie eine nebelmaschine
wieder geschnitten zeigt daher komme ich
verstehe ja ich bin ein experte in den
pfosten und dann ist das schlimm oder ja
erlebt er sagt das stadtoberhaupt nacht
hatte ja ja deswegen nicht gekommen
deswegen hat er sich einen finger
geschnitten acht kaffee und die flasche
um flasche geben bogen wieso ich habe
kinder pflaster windows live satzverlust
ich einfach jetzt ist der könig kommt
den ich fasten muss gebe ich jetzt schon
mal die masse hier direkt rein und ich
hoffe daran dass hoch genug
wenn nicht könnte ich ihnen jetzt noch
bisschen hochziehen aber es passt er ist
passt
und dann am besten den zucker direkt im
streuer film und auf die oberfläche
geben
so kann man es wirklich schön
gleichmäßig verstreuen und es entstehen
auch nicht diese flecken bei uns mit der
hand macht wird immer bisher fleckig
daher hier schön im steuer und einfach
eine schöne zuckerschicht
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt der kuchen ihren ford
heißen backofen bei 200 grad ober
unterhitze nach dem backen ist noch ein
bisschen wackelig wird aber schön fest
wir noch fett gebacken ist
richtig
vor euren juni wenig com zeigt herr und
mein gott ich habe gedacht und kleine
sauer wo noch ein buntes infektions gray
doch
ja also wer kein blut sehen kann bitte
jetzt abschalten nicht umfallen gemacht
ja das ist chaotisch das moretti
schneidet kriegen abgebogen vom mittag
bringen und da wollen die meisten
unfälle passieren nein das kann kinder
plastischen männer pflaster
diesen chor alle drauf durch mauer und
qualle und das macht sich jetzt ganz
schnell wieder heil in bonn
ich bringe café raus dann wird ganz
schnell gesund so der kurze rahmen
kuchen und wie die ihres gesagt hat war
billig aber nicht mehr flüssig es hier
so ein menüpunkt guck mal hier an
guckt mal jetzt hier drauf ich warte mal
kurz siehst du das noch ein bisschen
flüssig aber das zieht noch nach und ich
lasse jetzt eben gleich komplett
abkühlen und danach können wir probieren
[Musik]
da ist das fertige am kuchen noch
schneiden und wie gesagt er wurde
richtig schön fest
wow vor allem ist er richtig schön
schneeweiß weil wirklich kein ei in der
masse ist jetzt eine expertin dazu
elektronische experte eigentlich kann
man nicht meckern weil es heftig konnte
ja also musste heute nicht entscheiden
welcher schmeckt besser bei deiner frau
dabei mir muss nicht sagen weil es
gleich das rezept ist dass sie
eigentlich fan von mittelstück echt ok
ich da noch die ecke gegeben
40 m wenn da alex fragt dann stimmt
genau so muss es sein
ich finde halt blechkuchen das geht so
schnell ich weiß nicht wie lange ich
gebraucht
eine viertelstunde vor trike machen
auslegen in ofen 20 minuten maximum und
dann habt ihr innerhalb von einer stunde
einen richtig perfekten rahmen kochen
nicht so süß herrgott den gibt's jetzt
hier bei uns draußen im garten denn da
sind noch einige die fleißig arbeiten
und ihr könnt das rezept nach machen
gerne könnt ihr nachlesen ob cellestis
blog.de wie ich wünsche euch viel spaß
dabei und wenn ihr kein großes blech
machen wollt könnt ihr auf meinem blog
einfach die umrechnung funktion nutzen
und das ganze auch unter rechnen oder
können das ganze auf eine runde backform
ausrechnet entweder die tat form
benutzen oder einfach den runden das
geht auch also bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]